[Music]
the city is for some glamorous
stimulating prosperous
only recently has it become dangerous
Jack I think I found something three
women were strangled over the last two
weeks you're on a lifestyle desk you're
not covering a homicide I think the
murders are connected
another woman was strangled just came
over the wire I'm killing the follow-up
you don't have a story how many women
have to die before it's a story
they just confirmed number four
police aren't talking never seen him
this tight-lipped about anything I don't
care if it's one killer of four we're
gonna catch whoever did this
Boston police hands on the wall we had
them we just let them walk away
everything lines up with them is history
the progression of the crimes everything
you know how many people have gone down
the rabbit hole with
it's a dead end every time with this
case what do you think you're gonna find
out there when is this gonna stop
Loretta I need you to call in a favor
be quick
I don't want to get fired tonight
any lawyer worth of dime would pick this
apart
[Music]
I want to use this paper to tear down
the police department if anyone else was
blowing it this badly we'd have put it
on the front page a long time ago I need
you to take down an address if I don't
call back in an hour give it to the
police Loretta
there's more than one lunatic out there
and you're going to get us both killed
a safe little world is just delusion